I did it and I'm comfortable and I
travel it's a good life it's such a good
life
I'm 70 I am 70 71 years old best years
of my life yes and he's not bad I feel
I'm right in between feeling really old
and still feeling young enough to be
able to do the things that I want to do
I wanted to position that there weren't
many people in that position that looked
like me when I bid for the position she
was like I don't know if you can do this
I looked around the department and I saw
the people doing I said well aren't
those humans sitting at that desk I'm
human so I can do it too
the rest is history as I say that was 31
years ago I married the same person
three times and so I put my children
through some very unpleasant experiences
at the age of 61 I was diagnosed with a
rare and aggressive cancer I definitely
felt my mortality so I'm it's balancing
doing the things I believe in and enjoy
with not knowing how much longer I'm
going to be able to do it with the
divorce and going back and forth for
three times okay I wasn't ready to give
up on it but there came a time where I
needed to give up on it you have to
forgive yourself
the city was trying to condemn this
low-income residents we were able to
rehab that what was nice for me was
seeing this first generation Japanese
immigrant woman when she moved back into
her apartment was in tears I feel like I
was a much better grandmother than I was
mother I know when my daughter moved I
spent that hour crying because I wasn't
going to have my granddaughter there my
grandson and that's when I reduced my
hours at work I said I'm not going to be
a grandma that they don't know being the
coordinator I tell them you know let me
know if it's not a good fit and I'll
change you so one little boy the tutor
wanted to be changed but she said he he
has too many questions so I took him but
when I took him is that I found that he
was just very intelligent he was very
inquisitive but really got to me though
was that one week when we came back he
came in the door and said I'm a genius I
was genius and I was like tears like now
he said I got a hundred percent on my
spelling test and I thought that was
just I did that I helped him do that the
misconception that so many young people
have is that when you grow old
everything Jade you lose stuff you don't
your mind and your desires and your
drive stay the same they're there it's
just that your body can't fulfill but
wishes but I went ziplining it's 55
years old and I mean it was an adventure
I was mature eight but just go for it
you know the night before my surgery
where they did not know what they were
going to find they knew it was a large
tumor summed up things I said you know
I've got a good life it's a life of
purpose it's a life of doing the things
I believe in I don't have a bucket list
anymore I may have something tomorrow
that I never thought maybe hold on do
that I'm living my bucket list daily I'm
doing what I want to do right now when
one dies you know you don't look at the
date of birth and the date when they
died but you look at the dash in between
what's important is what did they do
during their life
don't let the passions that fuel you
when you were younger die out go boldly
into the future and boldly into your
maturity because it's a wonderful thing
its life cycle it's wonderful embrace it
is cool I'm happy
you